in under five minutes can you give us
the best screenwriting advice be be
different don't just because you read a
book on screenwriting don't follow an
exact format read screenplays read every
screenplay you can from amateur to
professional look movies you've watched
get those screenplays especially sites
like I don't even know if it still
exists for like guru script or AMA or
anywhere that the houses screenplays are
especially if you live in LA there's
stores sell them I try to get early
drafts of scripts and understand the
changes that they made to production I
think the more you read and see the
evolution of how writing is changing
over the years how character development
and dialogue and just all the different
I think it's about looking at all the
different because you know that there
isn't one set format for writing a
screenplay there used to be it's not so
much anymore but I think the more you
you read you just filter through this
works for what I'm doing this doesn't
work but you just see the way that
people use description it's just
practice and for indie filmmakers don't
shoot your first draft your first draft
is not perfect I mean unless you're the
next you know Robert Robert Towne or you
know somebody somebody who's got just
this amazing ability to kevin smith with
clerks even my baby that wasn't his
first draft like just because you
finished it and it was really difficult
doesn't mean it's perfect
so get feedback stage table reads listen
to the advice that people give you even
if you don't like it you're always gonna
fight for some things you don't have to
take everyone's advice you will never
not learn something you didn't think of
or didn't see as being a problem in your
script the more people you ask to give
their feedback in their input now of
course sometimes you want to do
something weird and wild that people
want to understand and that's okay you
don't have to change it but you have to
rewrite and rewrite and rewrite get that
feedback because it's so important to
shape there's no way that any one writer
can have all the answers and and bang
out a perfect screenplay with them that
guidance and help did you ever think
what your life would be like if you
hadn't gone to that Third Eye Blind
concert
probably be shooting wedding videos and
Windsor Ontario
yeah I'm not I'm not sure what would be
it would be different I think I've got
I've got the fight in me and I've wanted
to make movies for a long time it would
have figured figured out a way could be
it's a thing you can't think about right
you know because the the sliding doors
effect like with poltroon would be a
more the butterfly ripple if I got a
more traditional way would I be making
the experimental movies I'm making now
maybe not maybe I have more success
working in the studio system or four
television networks but it would be
wildly different because you know that
that also just taught me I started
sneaking into everything as long as I
wasn't breaking the law you know I met
my wife sneaking into a party in the
Toronto Film Festival definitely
wouldn't have done that had it not
worked previously so successful with
bands and I've used it to sneak in the
events where I know I could meet people
that could potentially read scripts or
take a meeting with say it would be
wildly different
you